all right and I think we are live
we're definitely live welcome everybody
to episode 105 of the iron Lords podcast
as should be painfully obvious to anyone
who listens to our show on a weekly
basis I am NOT your host Lord cognate
I'm not here to spread the gaming
realness I'm not here to say anything
about the YouTube streets and I'm
definitely not telling you what you want
or need to know it is just me Lord
sovereign fraud in lording and I
usurping because uh God gave me the keys
to the castle this week and he made the
biggest mistake of his life you know
just realize you
they better be no switch talk as you
outnumbered today I'm totally out of it
today
whether they definitely the little pack
sees recap yeah but definitely merica
call gave me the keys to the castle
today and I'm sorry to say that when he
comes back everything's gonna be imma
change all the passwords it's gonna be
Lords and sovereign dotnet changed
everything up but but real talk
shout-out to cog he is away he should be
on his way back from paying his last
respects to our friend Lord whisky so
shout out to COG have a safe trip back
and we will see you back at the
roundtable next week
but in the meantime let me introduce the
rest of the four horsemen of gaming
first our own now I'm not giving you it
I'm not doing that that's his Desa
slaying I'm just gonna introduce you in
that you just run with it but we got the
young wolf of the IOP the difficult game
Conqueror and the almost sucky row game
Conqueror is that true that correct I
only got like three or four balls but uh
it's rough I'm struggling
have you how many times have you wanted
to uninstall the game never never ever
since I stopped okay okay that's not
true I remember I there was before I
started getting down this parry system
because the way my mind works in these
games is I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
guard the only thing I'm gonna do is
like you are never gonna see me put up a
shield but this game is like okay who
gonna break me or you I guarantee you
you first all right I get you
I'll start guarding and ever since I
started getting out of the mentality
which sucks is that they make another
like dark so for instance they said
they're not going to but they make
another blood-borne
I'm gonna have to reprogram my mind
again to play like that no but I tell
you like I feel the same way about that
game like for me I have to I learned I'm
not dodging too much I'm standing right
in front of you and I'm powering
everything you throw at me and I'm gonna
break your stance I'm gonna break your
posture and that's the way I'm gonna
play the game even if you murder me a
million times the dodging is cool it
looks pretty but you really need to
master that pairing if you don't master
the pairing it done forget it give it
all up so anything else man you've been
playing anything else besides that we
missed you at PAX East with that said
let me introduce the Incredible Hulk of
this the excess gamer and a buzias gamer
of all IOP with some new things in the
background that I really want to talk
about I want to hear about these things
Laura King was going on my brother oh
shut up y'all a shout out the thing see
that Lee yeah let's talk a little bit
about what's in the background over
there's a few different things or
doesn't exist yet not does it I don't
know what it is it's look like it says
our King King that's what it look like
no why are you talking you went you went
in that alleyway then closing it took it
out of a dumpster I don't know what it
is
I don't know what that is I can't even
colors but what I can tell you is right
next to it impact me and then also
pac-man is inside that but a whole bunch
of other stuff six thousand seven
hundred and some other games yeah so you
are like overnight he sort of become the
goat of this this this YouTube thing
dude you got three shows going basically
what's going on man whoa I'm basically
I'm fighting hard baby I'm fighting hard
right now right now I'm in the bushes
from fighting get the hell out of it um
but now I'm trying to just give you all
a peek into what I do like my statue
join me playing video games for real
because a lot of you out here frauding
like oh I really play guys I shut the
hell up really young I know you don't I
know I'm being on all day I'm yelling I
don't see your breath so cut it out um
but now just a peek into my join my
world what I do my normal weight I'm
it's gonna be a whole bunch of other
stuff but people put up opinion pieces
on Lords of game of net on so you can
get a peek in today's world because when
when they give you an opinion piece they
actually given you um he's my voice is
done
they actually giving you a piece of you
know what's going on with them so
everything I appeal does um attic when
he does his reviews he's gonna be a
piece into his world and I always watch
all of his stuff so I mean just come
watch our world so this week I've been
playing Bloods name I think that is an
amazing castlevania metroid age type of
game it takes me all the way back to
when I first played original Castlevania
um the graphics is 16-bit I've been
playing Borderlands because I've never
played Borderlands I mean the first time
I put on this is I was fraud um you know
but um it's hot and my son played it
more than me so he was showing me shut
up shut your mouth but this is
definitely a nice game um and division
I'm terrified
so I'm owning you know how fraud I
played the first weekend and I had
don't have nothing say we add the virus
let's add to forget red I've said I've
doubled total fraud no we know how about
add them so tell me a little bit about
that that man in the background man a
segue into you to know a little bit of a
PAX East recap you know we weren't I
know we had a little you know our little
uh inebriated mini podcast over there we
talked a little quickly about what we
saw and our final thoughts on it yeah um
I love pax
I won't trade it for the world the level
of intimacy we have with all the
developers and stuff like that going
there 101 like you just walk up to me so
I'm talking about they gave me a hot
game around it's yo can I record your
game can I record you can we talk about
this can we get you out there let's see
more about this game and there's so many
indie games but I wanna tell you my
Nintendo is the king of the show out
there alright um 90% of that stuff is on
switch 90% of all that stuff is on
switch and if it's not on switch it's
coming hey hot stuff we got a lot of hot
stuff man I really was so pleased with
the future of my switch but I was
noticing something so ya see some of
these games looking like they was like
advanced switch games like my guess
which can't do that but how is they
making it dude like I said I said on
that stream I said did something tells
me that some of these devs have may have
an idea of what's coming down the
pipeline you know we all heard about
those rumors about two switches coming
out one more powerful one one smaller to
sort of bring the 3ds group over yeah
there were some things we saw out there
said what the hell and this is coming to
switch me up yup they a lot of games
they may not have had the Swiss version
ready they're us a lot of them they did
but literally damn near everything that
we saw on that show floor that wasn't
you know triple-a from you know a
well-known publisher was coming to
switch
what's though in one scene right it was
one see oh shout out to one see
entertainment Loki and addict knows
about these guys these guys are Loki the
goat of the indie developer along with
I'm wrong we like to vulvar these guys
everything these guys drop if you're
like have any sort of nostalgia for like
old-school fps RTS with like Final
Fantasy Tactics anything that you could
think of old-school these guys have gone
in and made something new in that vein
that's just absolutely fantastic they
see these games run beautifully and
every year is something new like I don't
even think the games that they showed
last year are all out yet and this year
they had all new stuff except for one
which was the other tactics game what's
the name of tactics game again addict
it's called fel so right exactly
I'm be honest man these guys that won
see are absolutely freaking fantastic
man it like literally everything that
they saw it was like really you guys are
doing this and how big is your team two
people five people that's about it it
didn't go much more than that and shout
out to all the like the the publishing
teams out there that they were sort of
talking to us if a dev wasn't around
anything like that these guys were so
knowledgeable and so charismatic about
every single one of the games in this
stable it was it was awesome to be there
man it really was it is definitely a
vibe that I enjoy I can't wait to go
back next year and you know honestly man
like we do just go hard cuz if you're a
small outlet getting two packs I think
is imperative after seeing how things
run over there and like and just seeing
the way that show is it's imperative if
you want to put your name out there you
want people to know about you and and
see the hard work that you're doing
going to show like packs to me is
absolutely 100% imperative because these
guys are there they want you to talk to
them they're more than willing to help
you out in anything that I mean they're
so forthcoming that's what you need to
be yeah yeah you know III is fantastic
and I know III is evolving in me we may
see more of that which I hope we do
start saying at e3 where people are more
sort of inviting to people that aren't
necessarily only on media but man I
loved it I loved it I can't wait for
next year all right so let's move on
to what we do at the beginning of every
single month as we say thank you to our
patrons you guys are the best of the
best fantastic you guys are always here
with us from the very beginning so
obviously we love doing this part and in
the fact that it's a small group of you
guys I love it because this is the guys
that I hear all the damn time and the
first in the chat monkey punch listen I
put up the link for the for the show
super early like I did it last night I
think and so I come in this morning just
to check on it and they're people like
monkey punch likes to make sure that
whatever the when he wakes up he goes in
to make sure he's first in the chat as
the leave so that was like three hours
before the show started so we thank you
guys for the dedication all right so let
me run through these names so first off
Lord Xavier Medina and I'm not putting
out his government that's all there is
there there's no alias aka nothing so
lord I fear Medina thank you for the
support brother much appreciate it all
right after that this is a patron that
I'm gonna call off forever patron this
is our friend
this is Lord Korey lydic AKA reaper 5912
AKA lord whisky he will be off forever
patron thank you so much brother for all
the support you've had for us from the
very beginning rest in power my brother
all right after that the PlayStation
brah thank you so much for your support
man can't wait to see you out there
III followed by Lord QX seven masters
thank you so much for the support man
appreciate it the man with the best -
best pic on Twitter and the internet
anywhere slow-mo back slap I have to say
it every time I said because I love that
pic I love the saliva flying is
fantastic and we had Lord Hakeem HB 33
Hakeem is new so thank you so much for
your support brother thanks for jumping
on and believing in what we're doing I
really appreciate it all right and then
we're followed by Lord fastback 67-68
been with us for a minute thank you
brother for the support
followed by Lourdes six six six nine
thank you so much for the support man
another one has been here with us for a
while all right
then with the man with the best arm be
named in the business John love aka
vagabond oh sorry I did it again John
backhoe vote thank you for the support
red followed by Lord sincere cantana
thank you so much
then our brother our brother gaming
Forte always out here supporting man we
really appreciate the support member and
another brother from the multiverse Lord
Undead coming in and supporting the Lord
thank you so much man you've been there
from the jump
thanks for coming along for the world
for the ride with us we really really
really appreciate it
followed by the wall of bill Lord bills
still well thank you so much the king of
X cloud thank you so much for the
support and of course followed by the
first one in the chat always always the
first one in the fan and I hope is very
first patron Lord Michael Lugo aka
monkey punch thank you so much Mary then
we have Lord Sammy Prescott
so wait up to like 20 22 patrons or
something like that so this list is
getting longer so we really appreciate
the support guys alright and now we have
Lord J font of course brother and
Friends of the realm always looking out
always always giving positive support
Lord J Fonz if you don't watch his
videos please go check out his come out
today Fonz is amazing then we have the
king of the stream team himself Lord PD
Lord snow thank you so much man yeah for
everything you do man like honestly at
PAX East I really saw how you get down
man your OCD is it is imperative in
these situations man but thank you so
much for being there man we appreciate
it and of course family from the cradle
to the grave Lord ambered aka loaded
pixels
thank you my brother Oh
support and always supporting Lambert
and if I am bird and bird oh does mark
oh yeah that's cold that's cold and of
course Lord fat fat daddy see I'm doing
what we're adding does look at daddy
facts acts thank you my brother
here's a slight case of dyslexia little
bit just a little bit just a little bit
intra dyslexia and of course last but
never least our friend from across the
pond Lord debt singer thank you so much
for the support brother you've been
there from the jump as well we
appreciate everything you do for us and
again it's thank you God saying I
thought you said you're supposed to be
doing our intros or something what
happened he did they don't wanna go
though I mean definitely gonna do it
again yeah come back and do it again
that's that's for sure alright so let's
get into these giveaways real quick oh
yeah make sure let's give away some
stuff alright so we must start off with
this this $10 gift card giveaway right
so the winner of the $10 gift card
giveaway
Lord sincere cantana thank you so much
for the support brother Lord sincere
congratulations on the $10 gift card
giveaway I'll be sure to have that in
your DMS later today so just let me know
what what system you want to follow up
I'll get that right - you better be
getting bugs bugs and be impressed
that's a job better be doing turn yo $10
into 200 games around so now let's go
for this $20 gift card giveaway you know
there might be an issue with that but
that's okay we will keep that between us
you know how we do you know how to iron
bank so the winner of the $20 gift card
giveaway is Lord vagabond Doe aka JL I'm
not gonna say a name again bag of wood
congratulations on the $20 gift card
giveaway I will be sure to have that
info on your DMS again just let me know
hit me up I know you was just paying
that man off because you couldn't say
his name probably twice twice I gotta
make sure I take care alright then so
let's go to our teespring giveaway our
final giveaway of the day of the month
t-shirts
yeah it's he shirts mugs whatever you
want except for that hoodie that hoodies
- premium you know so low but everything
else everything else goes ok so the
winner of our teespring giveaway for the
month of April is oh we've been doing
all along yeah our friend gaming Forte
wait a minute isn't that the game stop
dude yeah man gaming fourth day he knows
all about that pac-man he knows all
about that pac-man with their brothers
that over there thing geek yo
congratulations gaming Forte I think
there was no I was no motor said it was
rigged okay
so I slowed more that payment and gets
me in time you know you gotta be a
little more a little faster with your
payments man and I'll take care you so
that's what we have on our patreon for
this for this month thank you so much
again for the support guys you guys
already absolute best so let's move on
into our topics we don't have I I always
find it difficult to find the damn poll
results so I didn't do a poll I've
brought in on the poll I'll let [ __ ]
take care of that when he comes back
next week and we'll get back until that
poll stuff I'm gonna leave that alone so
let's jump directly into our topics for
the day so I'm gonna start off the Lord
King King we have we have some some some
services coming together to form Voltron
what was going on Oh JA Dominus out I
told y'all I told y'all what was gonna
happen yeah I wasn't knocking they're
not gonna do that
Oh soon game pass and Xbox Live there's
gonna be one service under God it's
$14.99 they're gonna get that and I knew
that was gonna be the way to um like to
to bridge the gap like if you put it on
another system right like it it just
only made sense that those services was
linked because a lot of the games needed
those services so if it's on another
system another platform those services
were there so the PC dudes that we're
getting game passed out there all day
you know they got past the barrier now
the barrier is still there 1495 got them
all for you today that's right you and I
the switch needs it the switch
definitely needs I think more than
anything
you gotta see switch sales go through
the roof
if they get game pass on a switch and
you can mean a voice chat and you have
your trophies and all that stuff that's
going to be the portable Xbox system so
tell me you really believe that game
pass in all its glory it's full
iteration is
gonna be on this which cuz I for me I
feel like it's more like live you're
gonna have your games that they already
announced like the cup head and more
than like the aura is gonna be a
downloadable game that it'll be it'll
just be like a cross published thing but
you really believe you were gonna have
all of game paths on the switch I think
Microsoft when they say they want game
paths everywhere it's not gonna be a
limit to it I really don't think that I
think you'll be playing Halo infinite
when you switch I really don't think
that they're gonna limit you in any
capacity when it comes to game path
because then that's gonna water down the
product so instead of saying um you know
okay it's a piece again pass you can't
say it's a piece of game pass when
somebody's on Xbox even Oh game pass or
somebody's on a PC in the full game pass
and switch get a limited game past but
they 14.95 know it's gonna be the same
game pass across the board's anywhere
you go for that price and you're gonna
have the same suite of features that
goes along with that 1495 yeah I mean I
agree with that is they cannot break up
the messaging with this it would be hard
because they've that's the problem
they've had in the past where people who
have had issues with numbers like the
messaging is always cloudy they don't
they don't they don't necessarily know
seem to know how to talk about their
stuff without confusing people who
aren't necessarily in the know like us
like us we research this stuff we know
what we're talking about we can complain
and [ __ ] about the fact that it's not
clear to people who may not be in the
know but I think they have to make a
concerted effort for that to not be the
case and anybody who looks at this stuff
from the outside can say okay this is
what it is I just have an issue with
thinking that it's not that did all this
stuff obviously it's gonna if it's gonna
happen and you're gonna get everything
that game pass has to offer on a switch
it's gonna be using X cloud in some way
shape or form right obviously
we don't know how powerful this this is
supposedly rumored you know switch 2.0
is gonna be so you know it could be a
massive leap over what's there now
though that's not Nintendo's way but
being that you know it's rumored that is
two SKUs
who knows who knows so tell me addict
what do you feel about this I mean I
just $15 a month like I get that you
know technically that's five dollars off
any of them that you choose it could be
five dollars off game patch could be
five dollars off live but I do feel like
you know they need that that 50% off
both services if you maybe feel like a
hundred dollars a year yeah it's like
right that's the biggest like I don't
you think that you know if they wanted
to do that like the problem is is you're
you're not charging other platforms for
the same service but instead of making
it beneficial for us at the same price
what do you do you raise what would make
it more beneficial and I'm not for that
I'm sorry like you forget it raised it
well I don't know a month now like if
you if you get that you know that
combination service so you mean to tell
me that I can either pay $10 a month for
something that everyone pays for with
that all the console people pay but you
know the the switched people that's not
really been confirmed so we won't bring
that up but you know the PC I'll pay for
the Android people don't pay for because
they party oh I think that's gonna go to
way too dinosaur I think all that is
gonna go away that it's not gonna be an
option but I don't think it is just
because they combine these two they're
trying to combine them I think in a long
term and that long term it makes sense
to combine them right I think one of
Microsoft's problems is that again they
don't know if you're not a game or if
you're not in the Microsoft ecosystem
you may not know that all these
different services necessarily interact
with one another it's just because you
just may not know that they need to
consolidate it in a way that makes sense
at the same time I don't at $15 a month
you're not getting any savings right
there like if you break it down it's
still the $60 a year for live gold right
and then it's the $10 a month that
you're paying right now for game pass so
it's still the same so III do think
you're gonna see package deals like
anything else like I don't think I've
ever paid any more than 40 dollars a
year for Xbox Live Gold atom I've never
paid $60 for it and then when it came to
I think when I initially got it I got a
deal on it but now I just out of lazier
laziness I just paid it $10 a month and
they just take it right off my card so I
think that's my issue with it is it's
not even necessarily a I have an issue
that they don't charge the PC community
for it they use the same services and
I'm just like you know when you could
have made things better you did what you
just tried to it like you try to wrap it
in a nice little blanket it's like this
is it's different but really it's not
you unwrap it it's the same thing
shout out to Forte in the in the chat
because for take a man said he said they
might have found a clandestine way of
charging PC and Swift gamers stuff that
that Xbox people have been paying for
forever but are they going to need that
service to play that on PC yeah because
we need that service to play it on
console they're gonna need it I think
what they have to create a reason for
you to what have it so I whether they
they actually need it no at the end of
the day like how are they gonna charge a
PC crowd when they don't need Xbox Live
now so you're gonna charge PC people $15
a month for pretty much just game pass
they get out they don't and then another
thing we have to think about is that I
don't think this is they're done folding
stuff into one another I think somehow I
think when you talk about the ultimate
package you start you have to start
thinking about how they got a price X
cloud right so that's gonna fold it in
there somewhere I think this is just
again the beginnings of them showing you
that they're gonna tear off these these
things but I don't think this is the end
of it this is just the beginning this is
the tip of the iceberg everything else
is coming like again one once they start
talking about pricing for X cloud
obviously that's something that I don't
think you know how many people do you
feel are gonna be saying I'm X cloud
primary is that gonna be the case you
have to fold it into this no I just I'm
not about this direction like you know I
always thought they would drop the the
you know the multiplayer behind the
paywall
they would try off
but now that they're trying to find
convenient ways for both services
together I don't think that's the plan I
do think they're gonna continue to
charge us online for the console play
because they know that at the end of the
day you know a lot of these console
people are casual they don't even know
pcs not paying for it
right so and I just I have a problem
with that because I feel like this is
the perfect time you had an opportunity
to fix that
opportunity because you're making half
of your demographics what I even hath I
don't even know how many people actively
plays on Windows but you're making a
part of your demographic pay for
something the other parts not and
instead of making the part that is
paying for more you know it you know
obviously on console oh I see what
you're talking about out of making the
part that pays for it more convenient
okay I understand okay they they might
not have to pay for multiplayer and I
have to pay for it but at least I get
game pass with it like because that's
pretty much what's going on here they
want us to pay the game pass and they
want us to pay for Xbox Live Oh what we
want is for people to have game pass so
I see what you're talking about and what
you're with you're upset with you
talking from the console standpoint and
PC dudes is still running around free
I'm just like Jay Fonzarelli said forget
PC right but well Microsoft doesn't want
you to do is forget PC when they give
you this suite of stuff and I think
sovereign is on to it that X cloud is
going to be included into that that
whole package is going to be justified
for that 14.95 that people have to get
into this and they're gonna get that
game pass into your home by any means
necessary that day with you know with
the PC dudes talking about they're
playing and they don't have to pay for
this that's done it's done so they have
to pay for this to get to that so none
of that free stuff that whole thing is
gonna go away they want you in one
centralized area playing the same way
paying the same way as everybody else so
I'm down for 14.95 for all I'm now for
yeah I think
the thing with that is that it's one of
those you know changes change is always
difficult change is destructive and
we're always gonna push back against it
but I think if they want to make their
idea of a view of unifying this platform
in the way that they want and have
everything under this one umbrella
that's good it's gonna be something that
the PC crowds gonna have to eat and I
don't know that they will I don't they
will right they might be might find that
whatever Microsoft is offering in the
exclusives realm the ground doesn't
matter to them and they'll just you know
go to whatever other story exactly go do
whatever else they want but I think if
this is I'd it doesn't make any sense to
fragment it like King said it just
muddies up the messaging again if you
start fragmenting this this person
doesn't get that this person doesn't get
that display looking at that it's a
tough sell because they have if there's
one thing they came out of the stadia
announcement that I liked is when they
talked about each one of those the
different aspects of it it all fell
under the same umbrella and it all felt
like it worked together in conjunction
to form one product and I think
Microsoft's products do do that Xboxes
products do do that but they all have
their own name different naming
conventions they can all be used
independently one another if you're not
in the know oh who do we introduce
everyone was good oh yeah except for me
I said that I was usurping your power in
the kingdom you know we're gonna have
some combos about that yeah
you were stuck in traffic
you have to stop through when I see what
boy saw holding it down King with it
with King partying last night wasn't
kidding voice bro what's going on
nothing much we were talking about this
fiasco that they're trying to do with
combining the prices of Xbox Live oh
yeah instead of okay you know our
console people pay you know let's just
give them game pass just for cost so if
they pay for go out life is a show let's
right let's let's go okay it's like I
said they're the rapping like a cloth
around something acting like it's a new
product to be like inside it's the exact
same thing
oh it that yeah for sure young position
is like they jerky they jerk in console
like good like not be doing this
combination thing if they were about to
drop alive from consoles in general mmm
if they're combining these they have no
intentions are dropping it from confer
for Xbox Live they have no attention
they wouldn't even need to have this
conversation if their future plans was
dropping it from console now the thing
is we still have to talk about X cloud
right because that's an eventual thing
that we would assume is going to come to
the service right it's gonna be it
rolled into that that's for sure Phil is
out here breaking backs I think I think
solve is only I think this is like the
precursor to the bigger move I don't
know though I hear where attica's coming
from the problem is I just can't see
them walking away from that revenue
stream now I'm saying like that's a big
revenue stream to take away from console
as far as like removing the Xbox Live
barrier so I still think it's going to
always favor console guy I mean I'm
always in favor of PC guys and maybe the
mobile the future mobile guys as they
try to penetrate that cloud but yeah
I mean it's interesting they're already
starting to get the ball rolling with
that man but yeah I can make sense for
them to sort of muddy the messaging by
saying that these guys get this or the
other guy don't cuz that's the that's
the problem with them right there that's
what they always kind of have to have to
sort of defend against you know people
like us the comments on it is like okay
why it's different on this platform as
opposed to this yeah it's taboo no cuz
it's like we all know it's unfair as a
console gamer there any have to pay that
I mean shout out the damn McCullen we
had them on and they were talking about
you know he hinted that they would do
some changes the problem is its services
and Xbox Live is so much a part of their
revenue stream I just can't see them
saying unless I mean if they combined
all the services maybe what people
walking away I just say what's up
oh no doubt sir much appreciated
have a safe trip man alright so just to
put a cap on this um honestly I'd like
we said before it's the tip of the
iceberg it has it has begun as they say
this is this is one of those first moves
that you see obviously another thing is
that it makes perfect sense with the
Xbox Shaddai just around the corner
people they just you know they're just
getting a download-only console
something like this absolutely makes
sense so I think it's the tip of the
iceberg I think we'll hear more about it
at e3
I think the role in 4x cloud is it's
probably well maybe they don't talk
about it III cuz we're not the service
isn't launching this year we'll just get
beta beta this year so it's not actually
launching so we may not get pricing as
of yet
at e3 but um yes the tip of the iceberg
man I'm interested to see what they do
to make this not feel gross for people
who haven't been paying for the stuff
before it's a a I broke into the rope is
no get you behind in life if you're not
in line down a stick that that's wrong
we do break a dumb missus are cracking
backs alright so moving on to the second
topic of the day and this is my topic so
Bioware and anthem I know everybody on
the net had talked about this to death
over the past over the course of the
week but we haven't talked about it yet
um
so Jason Schreyer wrote an expose
basically talking about what went wrong
with with the development of anthem
right and and how people how it's been
received since its launch right and
basically he broke down why the game
launched in the state that it launched
lacking sort of in content and features
um and it and it all pointed to an
environment at Bioware which sort of I
mean from every angle whether it came
from leadership not necessarily having a
real reason for the game issues with the
Frostbite engine in terms of going back
to leadership leadership leaving and
then coming back and then the thing that
they're mostly known for which is great
story and narrative and character
interaction that sort of stuff being up
in the air and and uncertain also kind
of attributing to the fact that the game
just didn't you know pan out the way
they they thought it would or it changed
in so many different facets over the
course of seven years of development
that it was almost guaranteed that that
game was not going to be anywhere near
the product that we as gamers expected
and that they expected to release so
that was a super long article likely he
broke down so many aspects
of that development and just what
happened step by step so did you guys
read it you guys look into it what do
you think about it uh is it is it
surprising as you know by aware and they
mentioned this in the UH they mentioned
this in the article that there's
something that they with them by whether
they call the Bioware magic whereas you
know magically the last couple of months
of development or the last year
development the game comes together no
matter how hard development was open to
that point everything comes together and
they release a quality product with Mass
Effect Andromeda and now anthem it seems
like that magic is sort of run out so
what do you guys think about the article
do you think it was kind of a shot at
them do you think it was fair to talk
about this sort of stuff
and you think his this overall sort of
assessment of anthem because the tone of
the article was he felt the anthem is a
straight-up failure and I know how King
feels about it let's go at it first
let's go we're at ease I think Bioware
and EA are in the bushes I think that
they spent I don't know I didn't read
all the article we read some of it a
skim through it this is one for by Jason
all right yeah I actually watched angry
Joe cuz he brought down the whole thing
to like the highlights of it they need
I'm sorry like at the end of that like
Bioware they might need to go like did
you guys see some of the stuff that
happened with this like teams though
they took six years that only actually
developed this game from other over a
year yeah that is insane like they said
that they they switched back and forth
from wanting to have flying to not
wanting to have flying multiple times
mm-hmm so you know it's like Angry joe
said on their like they were they would
have to go back and redesign the maps in
the art design to to make it flying
accessible because not everything you
could do you know if people could fly
that high you actually have to read to
how they let have the map interacts so
you can't fly out of the map because I'm
sure a lot of these places don't even
have
a border you know like if you could
that's why a lot of these games if you
do any kind of mod and you go up you
just keep going up because that because
you're not supposed to be up that high
anyway you break the game when you do
that like completely yeah I mean it
makes it makes sense like that again it
is so much of this game that it works
right because I I think everybody has
said like when it comes to locomotion
the flying that's all cool the overall
premise they think can be something good
too great but just the execution and the
content isn't there I think they've been
working towards fixing bugs like that I
know there was a bunch of you know
crippling bugs early on when the game
launched obviously they're fixing that
along the way but I think one of the
things that sort of pissed me off about
what I read in the article was that they
went into it without even they didn't
want to take the lessons learned from
Bungie with destiny they didn't really
want to actually what's funny is they
were like you couldn't even talk about
destiny no no they wanted to be 4d they
wanted the comparison to only be with
Diablo 3 and not destiny and that
doesn't make sense because if you're
making a game in the same vein look at
their missteps and don't make the same
mistakes same thing with uh with the
division why would you not look at the
division and look at the mistakes they
made and look at how what they've done
to rectify those mistakes and make sure
you don't come out of the gate making
those same mistakes it's funny when we
first talked to when we talked about
this game after they showed it at e3 and
and you know there was excitement around
what it was um I said there's no way
well okay I was excited initially I have
to say I was excited everything was
about the game was a fraud from the
moment you saw that the vertical slice
you knew that it wasn't you knew that it
wasn't what they claimed it was gonna be
but at the same time I said okay you
know what they have hindsight they've
seen yo they've seen everything that
made
mistakes common sense with EA in them
dudes and we all know they have never
used a shred of common sense like
there's multiple reasons that that made
it to where it is now one yeah it wasn't
no I don't even want to blame this 109
yeah like I would blame this 60 on
Bioware and 40 on EA I would blame EA
because they took some of the stuff that
was helping them away from them like
they had the pillar they had an engineer
team that was there at the beginning
helping them with the Frostbite engine
they pulled them away to do FIFA -
exactly no that's because their mandates
of what they wanted and what they wanted
the game to present but you cannot say
this isn't Bioware's fault when they
took six years and didn't develop
nothing great two months I can tell you
this right if EA wasn't hell-bent on
putting that force bite crap on
everything so these dudes don't have to
pay royalty fees to arm epics engine
that's huge if they would have used the
Unreal Engine the game would look better
we're gonna had this stupid what's that
um blur that I cannot stand like hey
like they built this this engine because
they want all of their stuff to be used
with their engine with the money right
but the problem is is you can't make a
game that's brand new with this engine
and not expect like the engineers should
have been there through the whole
development but hey once it seems like
once the engine was finished they don't
have a support team there to help you
figure stuff out when stuff breaks it
just seems like they throw the engine
out into the wild to the teams and let
the teams figure it out as they use it
and then they have to make different
tools according to what they need for
their specific game that's ridiculous
why would you saying before why I knew
this game was gonna be a failure I told
y'all before what it was gonna be why
it's gonna be a failure it wasn't it has
nothing to do it none of that stuff did
these dudes is unearthing cuz I'm pretty
sure a lot of game similarly has
checkered pasts and all this other stuff
that glitch with him mmm-hmm what I knew
was gonna happen
this game was division 2 was coming out
destiny was gonna be ramping up fixing
all the stuff that was wrong with that
there's gonna get us a little mojo going
and during this whole period of time
pocket games have been dropping that set
the bar so high in your bed a game that
is mediocre that is trying to grab its
legs and move forward is no longer
viable in this environment look at
fallout 76 the games are not going to
survive if it comes out these these
developers have to understand that now
you cannot put out crap and expect it to
catch wings and people to eat it they're
not doing it and almost too much to
choose from when you're gonna say I'm
gonna I'm gonna choose this crap I'm
gonna stick with this crap you don't
have to you can just move on to
something else and let that thing die so
services like the epic store or or the
game pass or something like that with
those games should go and get legs and
people start to play it like warbound
what was that warframe when warframe
first came out it was crap to me and it
got better over a period of time but
that time is not gonna be given the
anthem because nobody is willing to
invest all that money in a game that
after a couple of hours you had a dead
end
there's no content yeah addict REI but
that just went crazy could smooth this
industry but I was just trying to answer
them sue they'll be here in a second
calm down you guys it's like I said man
I ain't never been a big fan of this
anthem stuff I ain't never liked it
ain't never been around it I've always
been the anti anthem seeing this is
maybe believe 100% that Bioware is not
what Bioware used to be you can't stay
here and go into that and say stuff like
that it's that oh we're not going to
compare this to destiny but when the
game comes out it has a lot of destiny
like features and I just I don't
understand
where
like I don't understand how you go that
long and development but you you're
actually not developing the game until
the last 16 months like I literally not
I can't fathom that I cannot well
remember when they did that the 2017
thing the that wasn't even in the game
like they haven't even they barely just
started production on it that's the
funny thing they barely just started and
now we're getting into this the game and
oh you know they just laid a bunch of
people off like they intentionally and
it's like I said it's what I'm billing
Bioware I blamed Bioware more than I
blame EA because at the end of the day
EA did some stuff that hurt them but
Bioware is the one that wasted six years
of development time I think yeah I think
you're right ie I think you have to look
at they weren't forced to make this game
they wanted to make this game right the
fact that they they kept relying on an
outdated method of making games and
again that's not only them I'm not
saying that they're the only ones are
there but they are definitely to blame
and this is something that's that's sort
of endemic of the entire gaming industry
this crunch stuff it doesn't make any
sense because at this as long as you're
working on a game if you do have
direction right if you do have vision
and you know exactly what you're what
you're trying to get at and you know
that from a technical standpoint it's
feasible then it could get done but
that's not that's not what happened here
it just seems like everything was up in
the air where there was story whether it
was tech stuff whether it was how to
build stages how to build missions
everything from top to bottom was a
train wreck and they allowed it to stay
that way in hopes that at the end all of
it would come together and form a game
and they said it they even said in the
article like low key the success of
Dragon Age Inquisition messed us up
completely because that game was was the
the the the prime example of what should
not happen during development of a game
and because we got recognition for it
it's coulis over because that that
became the expectation at both Bioware
and EA so it's like it's just one of
those things where I can I can't not
make by where
culpable in this they the culture has to
change and it's not only a Bioware thing
it's just because we're talking about
and we spotlighted it but this is a
culture thing within gaming that I think
has to be addressed because you can't I
don't know jack about developing games
and I know most developers will tell you
yo the game doesn't come together to
look like the end sometimes you don't
need it happened with the Last of Us I
think that in it of itself is weird how
can you not know going into you know the
last two years of development what you
think your games gonna feel like and
play like and what its gonna be and if
you and if it's good or not that's so
weird because it feels so super
disjointed and again when it when it
starts affecting people's mental health
and and and and and their sanity and and
you know the fact that they you know
again you're teetering your job is
hearing kind of on it I got a vault as
well because if it doesn't do well they
couldn't make it shut down your you know
your studio just like that and in
Bioware above all else they they needed
to be saved by this game and I don't
think it's done that and it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens
because I just don't but at the same
time I think I can't blame EA completely
for this because they allowed this
culture to continue within their
development studio I hope this is a huge
thing I hope they realize that they
can't keep doing it like apparently this
exact same thing happened where they
took very little time to actually
develop the game happen will Dragon Age
Inquisition and they when they did they
interview with them he said he kind of
like he didn't want the game to fell
obviously that's you know that's what
they're working on but at the end of the
day he was like do we show EA that this
works we don't want that but you know
they got lucky Dragon Age was mainly
highly received by everyone
so what did EA do let's try it again
it looked like it blew up in their face
do me a favor soft send me on our
Facebook the link to this cuz kid it
won't the the link won't join for some
reason delinquent joined yes and send it
to me on Facebook continue
okay hold on so she the boss was good
boss
what's going on guys all right so let's
move on from this topic we've beaten
this to death although I do want to get
smooth input on this but he'll be here
soon if you want you can try to send it
to it you can call his email to see that
blip right his emails this if you want
to try it that way yeah I was taught
about that is it glow yeah it's going up
right now you're getting way too hype
over this fact Man Thing man look at it
oh my god oh all right yeah so I put it
over I don't have this opposed I don't
have the Facebook stuff so IIIi got it I
got it
I sent his email in there you can try to
call his email too if you want but um
it's like I said these companies need to
realize that this stuff doesn't work you
can't sell us a $60 game and then expect
everyone to be okay with it when it
comes out like anthem yeah and i'm
knowing it's bad for the industry like
it's showing publishers that they should
do whatever they want and i'm glad like
you know as much as pc people get on my
nerves and they get on my nerves
a lot of them within reason because some
of them just be crying crying and crying
but within reason some of them like no
we aren't about that we go stand up and
i had to give them that cuz console
people don't really got that option okay
we gotta talk to one person like we
ain't calling multiple different
launches okay when we call customer
services xbox or playstation like that's
all yeah yeah i just i think it's sad
dude i really do think it's sad and i
think i just said it also just another
failure game that's gonna get written
off and people got paid it wasn't like
they was doing it for free
oh it weren't damn fraud stuff people
I need a mental-health day toughen up
you know cookie cut the crap out like if
they bothering you quit you're not
forced to do anything you know you got
talent your talent will show you I'll
get another job someplace else but
somebody's forcing you to do something
quit you don't like it quit everybody
likes to yeah we talked about that
before like people talking about all
this you know all this toxic work
environment stuff and then but you stay
this it's a lie it's a fraud it's a it's
a reason to complain the game is crap
you don't like it don't buy it
like I told people that I was not buying
that game because it was too many red
flags going in and everybody kept trying
to bypass the red flag kept trying to
bypass the red flag all right I see
y'all I'm not buying that game and I'm
shoutout to L for a gift in the game I
play the game with them I play the game
with everybody that yell you want to
play it I will play it with the person
that purchases the game I will play it
with the team I want to get on a plane
if you're a patreon of subscriber I will
play with you I have no problem with
doing that I was just explaining to you
guys that it was not gonna get my money
because I knew a fact what it was gonna
turn out to be and the vision that was
worthy of that bread because they showed
the steps leading up to the new division
and I touched it when I was at UM fan
fest at e3 last year the gay I said oh
it really is what they said because when
I saw the division I was like letting it
and then I went and I played out so no
I'm sorry
um that game is not worthy of us even
keep everybody wants to figure out what
was wrong you know why because y'all
spend your money and y'all sitting there
hoping and praying but instead of
looking at the red flags on things you
just kept bypassing it and now you're
crying over spilt milk don't cry now you
paid your money don't cry now you should
have gave it back to him I guess what
Microsoft will give you your money back
the viewer reported that game back in
like two days after you got it but
you're getting you're stuck with it now
so so shout out to the chat I'm trying
to figure out who made the comment but
and we've talked about this in the past
so how does that how does that reception
change if this game is a free-to-play
game right just hypothetically or become
if it becomes that at some point is any
of this other stuff acceptable at that
at this point yep
completely I don't know why not why not
act I just feel like if a game is
promoted and marketed from the start is
a free-to-play then that makes something
but at the end of the day it's like if
you start something as a trip light on
its a six yellow title and then you know
you drop the ball weight even really
drop the ball like they blew up a whole
building but and then you do that it's
like okay now we have to do this because
we didn't meet quota because the game's
not doing well I feel like at that point
it's like now if people jump on it
because it's free-to-play then it's just
like okay this you could do this now is
you've already screwed us all with the
$60 purchase and but you know how these
people are yeah well what would what
will they do if they make it a
free-to-play they'll give us some skins
in you know like that is not the way
it's like if a game comes out like this
it just needs to flop it just needs the
flop Victor last year they had closed
doors to media all right now I'm Cognito
and I'm a couple of other people had a
chance to play the game I was stationed
at another area I did not get a chance
to play the game now when I spoke to cog
you know off the record you know he was
like it's cool they're gonna work on
some things and I didn't feel that it
was I didn't feel what he said to me
gave me solid ground to purchase his
game so when the pre-orders went up I
said I'm not gonna do it because I saw
it like I said way too many red flags
with the game now if they make it free
to play now who cares like if you
already purchase it you already in right
so who you think they're gonna market
this for like if that was too nice they
don't have to refund every one sixty
that's the only way that justice
well they you get I know it's not
happening but I feel like that's the
only way to make a free-to-play
justified it's like you can't charge
someone $60
for a price tag and because your game
clock let's make it free-to-play and
give like three skins to everyone how
can fix this game right and I've been
saying it and I know it sounds like I'm
a game past and but you take these games
that are considered failures in the eyes
of the public but in front of the
boardroom this game actually sold and it
was actually charting the first month
that it came out it was number one on
the chart there's more successful one
right in terms of sales yes so it
nervous all those pre-orders of stuff.if
and what they want to look at is
engagement in longevity of the games
because initial sales they don't care
for that all right that's nice to them
about what they want is longevity and
they actually want to see engagement
within the game because if the first
week you play the game and everybody is
super anticipating the game and playing
the game but after a week later then you
see a 50% drop off it's like movie sales
if it's a 50% drop off from the initial
week then you understand that you want
on pays for a flop so you would take
this game and you will put it into a
situation like game pass where you can
highlight it to all those people that
either didn't purchase it or was on the
fence to it to get their engagement
levels up all right so that's what they
want they want engagement levels up and
then you can sell them stuff inside the
store with guns and skins and colors and
all that other stuff that can go along
with it through the store but you have
to Trojan horse it to the people so they
can get it they can start playing it and
they can say well it's not as bad as
they said and they don't feel the
initial pinch of the $60 you understand
once you've got that pin for $60 and
you're sitting there saying and stand it
out I don't feel the content that's what
the frustration comes in it's like the
game past ultimate stuff like you hide
it so the it's not as painful it's not
painful and then again people are more
willing to jump in it just and it's just
optics man it could all be exactly the
same stuff but the objects it completely
I don't know man
uh I I disagree with King and that I
think it's a sad thing because I don't
think Bioware is ever gonna be the same
ever I don't know I don't even know
to think of what drag the next dragon
ages I didn't think it was the same
after they messed up with Andromeda I
actually played Andromeda I said man
this is not the game some people will
say from the end of Mass Effect 3 the
fact that they even forget about the
ending and what they decide to do you
know what that's their story that's that
that's their agency they can do whatever
they want when they went back on it yeah
that was a red flag for me because I
said wait a minute
why how is there so much indecisiveness
at the top that this even came up like
that wouldn't be a conversation that
even comes up in my mind like it is what
it is we were happy with it when it
launched that's it so I guys check it
out there's 82 of y'all in here is only
45 likes I saw them in a Google hangout
it thumbs down or put thumbs up but
getting me and put some thumbs around
let's sum it up let's go let's go let's
go let's do it
you got the column from an email it's
doing what does the king it kicks him
out no no it won't even let him join
because of that like we have to always
sing King the that's true yes so you
have you're gonna have to add I put his
email in there in the chat you're gonna
have to actually go up and push it
what's that you're heading through email
senator Zena I get it and then he can
just come through because I definitely
want to get at them on that whole sent
it I sent it from my email so yeah thank
you guys thank you for all those
dislikes dislikes that we ever had
obviously I'm missing Cognito get all
new dislikes baby get him back in here
baby rather you do something and do
nothing all right
understand action is the word alright so
let's move on to the next topic and when
smooth gets in here we'll retro actively
ask him about everything that we've
talked about to now but let's go get
into this hallo infinite and gears 5 I
was a little bit confused by a topic
addict I wanted to know what kind of
angle you were approaching it from I
want this talk halo infinite in Gears
like what I want to really bring up is
it's looking like that you know they
they I don't know necessarily with with
halo but I do know
that was rumor that they're spending a
lot of money on Hey look I was rumored
to be like around with destiny once
spent for the whole 10-year lifecycle
we're not ten years but you know that
fer that game with marketing and
everything and gears apparently they're
doing they're taking a huge risk on
Gears he said that they're not holding
back because they did on Gears for so
you know it's looking like Microsoft
might be giving a lot more of a say to
its studios and the developed and that
you know the the leads of their Studios
do you guys think that if you know Gears
comes out in and it's revolutionized
that the story is good the multiplayer
is good and halo comes out do you think
that would give a lot more clout back to
II back to Microsoft because I honestly
truly thing I don't know about gears
because I think Gears Loki sucks but you
know halo I'm about to go which one here
I mean they've been doing the same hide
behind cover the same I don't know man
um when they reckoned it and they they
said they a hyper-extended two graphics
I stood still a cartoony to me um I
thought they should go in another
direction with it I thought that was
gonna do that with the last Gears it's
the same gazed at me um but I honestly
do truly think that you know a good
concept when it comes to the multiplayer
of Halo and the single-player of a lone
if they get both these at all on the
right way that they need to I think that
alone could give the Xbox a lot more
clout because let me think about what
halo one did in Halo 2 you know it's
just been here recently that halo hasn't
had that cloud like the last six years
remember you're not gonna like disabled
I told you what it was gonna be you're
not gonna like this a little boy I have
to second be game has to actually come
out listen listen bro I'm telling you
ahead of time it ain't what you want it
to be it's gonna be what it has to be
what the industry has turned into so
that five hundred million is not gonna
be no a linear type of game now five
hundred million is for the expansiveness
of the game um they wants you to delve
into this universe they want you to
become your own master chief they war
you to be in that driver's seat to be
the hero of your home story
so when that stuff really takes flight
and you're able to plug down and really
dig into this world is it's gonna be a
different piece now that one I have hope
for that one I believe will put
Microsoft back on the map I honestly
believe that that halo intimate is gonna
stamp them back to excellent I don't
feel that that gives I don't do anything
close to anything like that's just gonna
be another burger to turn I agree with
you guys that that the last couple of
titles from both of them have felt kind
of a little bit stagnated I know that
the coalition with that good gears for
was solid but it was it was safe right
they didn't it's almost like they felt
like no we need to make sure we show
them that we can make a Gears game and
then with five we're gonna take it in
our own direction see any new direction
is the drill what I did see is something
that I like from original gears is that
if I like this the original gears felt
more suspenseful it felt almost horror
game like in some instances and I like
that I saw that but to say it but beyond
that to be honest like yeah I felt like
more the same it felt like it moved a
little bit faster I know it seemed like
she had some different weapons that sort
of made the movement feel a little
quicker and not as lumbering because
these guys you know you know when you do
that that roadie run it's the same
animation all the time and it feels
heavy in a way that I know a Gears game
is kind of supposed to feel but at the
same time I don't think III do think
they need to make some changes to that
I'm not a big fan of just hiding out
behind cover popping out shooting and
doing and then move on to the next thing
I like the fact that a game could allow
you to move from cover to cover more
quickly like if you look at look at the
division prime example the division the
enemies are so aggressive that they're
flanking you all the time much more than
in the gears game so I just have to say
something real quick
I apologize everyone in the chat I don't
think we're gonna be able to get kid on
here it's not working so something
specific has to be done with the solver
knows how to do it so I definitely
apologize for the UX
have to call him on go light the top
left they'll let you call just by email
it not singing email while and that's
what you have to do cuz I don't know
what's going on I've never had issues
yeah it's just not and this is not a
contingency that I was prepared for
learning on the fly guys you got a
letter my bad my bad so sorry smooth I
don't know why the links aren't working
I see you like the little plus button up
there you could click it I'll let you
send it by email I did that and nothing
happened
nada nah that's crazy yeah I did that as
well I did it direct and I did it
through the plus button and it's not
doing anything well you know Google
Hangouts as Google Hangouts
alright so beyond that like alright
let's go back to halo Infinite right
because I know you guys had a discussion
about this a couple weeks back when I
wasn't on the show I'll be honest yeah I
know attic had concerns that he felt
like look I'm not playing this game if
it's a game as a service and it's not
story based and it's not a chief story
I'll be honest with you guys I think
they're they're building if this is true
about this game has a 500 million dollar
budget and that's that's not including
you know advertising stuff I don't be
honest I think they're building a true
MMO like I mean and I mean MMO in the
sense the way the game is structured not
it's still gonna be a shooter you're
still good it's gonna be a straight-up
shooter it's gonna be story based but I
think they're building the Halo universe
I think that's what infinite means I
think they are literally building the
Halo universe as the base structure of
Halo games for the next probably decade
to come I think it's all gonna be story
based much like you have with an MMO and
you have you know we have expansion
packs that come out every you know six
months year whatever but I and and that
stuff is gonna be very story based but I
really do think they are trying to build
a straight-up Halo universe in the game
world and give you everything that
they've given you inside stories the
little side TV stuff that they've done
in the past the novels I think they
really want to give you that entire
universe so I think that's what the
honestly that's what I think it is I
would be a mistake to be a straight-up
game as a service I think would it be a
mistake to try to mimic destiny or any
of these other lunar shooters I don't
think it's that I don't I don't think I
don't think is not as is he is more
ambitious than it is what destiny
promised like going into the next
consoles right we know um the next
consoles is going to show you more power
when it comes to graphical fidelity is
going to show you more power when it
comes to CPU remember the architecture
of these consoles was limited by the
base consoles all the actors that we
have now other pro consoles that we have
now or a little bit more robust when it
comes to these calculations so going
forth into the future you're gonna want
to use you see like no man's sky right
right you take the premise of no man's
sky and then you take destiny and you've
merged that into that and that turns
into halo infinite you understand you
you you get the lunar aspect you get the
law of the story and all that story that
that um destiny has you have all that in
there you have all those missions you
have all that stuff but then you have
the expansive world because when you
look at destiny destiny is very limited
and that's and that's what I don't like
about it the fact that destiny as much
as they try to make it seem like it's a
whole world it's not because everything
is sectioned off right here I think it's
right everything is zoned off it doesn't
feel like one cohesive world so that's
what I think they trying to do with
infinite is to create literally a
cohesive world yeah no man sky but a
real no man's sky enormous sky will you
actually meet people if you ever compare
halo to no man's sky
what would you not what you're gonna
focus on a story stuff I think the story
is not going anywhere I think when you
land on a planet you're gonna go and you
wanna find a story that's in that planet
is gonna be like that RPG first-person
to shoot a mash-up but with a hole see
no mask I was a really good ambitious
premise the execution of it was wrong
now if you go back to that same game now
it's a little bit closer to what they
initially wanted you to get but when you
start breaking it down like you don't
really meet people the level of
interaction with other players is what
it's lacking now if you're able to
actually go into the world and connect
with people and going missions and do
things when a story layer built on top
then you can actually have a very good
viable game that will keep you playing
for years to come and that's what
they're trying to get you into I believe
and his core I think some of those
things are correct I really do I think
you know they people made it known like
once you know with Halo 5 all the lock
stuff and the fact that the story wasn't
what people thought it was gonna be
I think piss people off a lot I think
whatever they do I think narrative is
paramount and I think first out of the
gate is a chief narrative whatever it is
but I do think they're trying to craft a
humongous world killem we think they
kill them
I think why you think they kill adding
is not feeling you right now peers value
pure shock value they kill him
they blow his brains out they kill him
they kill him and you must you must find
pieces you must become the new chief you
your character must step into these
massive shoes you must become the new
chief they kill him are you doing that
[ __ ] what what happens if they do the
Attic they're not doing that they kill
Luigi kill him
oh he's not dead ghost Luigi's bug it I
think I could see them killing chief at
some point in the future but I don't
think they'd replace them with oh you're
chief now right
I don't think that helmet ain't cheese
helmet that dildos legs ain't cheese
legs
they specifically they specifically said
that the engine was gonna be more
streamlined that for whatever reason
you're not you know all the crazy like
textures in detail they put in from Halo
2 onward especially like Halo 4 and 5
like the suit looks crazy I think they
wanted to go back to a more simplified
look whatever you know again well I
guess we'll see what slipspace looks
like finally at e3 but I'm telling you
guys whatever this game is I really do
think that it's going to be a huge
departure at least from structure wise
that we're used to I don't know how
people are gonna take to it I want
something new I love you know I listen I
love the Bungie halo stories right
and then granted this is not they're not
Citizen Kane right we're not talking
about these not the greatest stories
ever told
oh really but they do know how to do is
give you a good summer blockbuster right
and I think what 343 hasn't been able to
do is that is give you that necessarily
right I think they're better at the
smaller storytelling I like the Cortana
story I love that don't they gotta be
able to do both of those things man is
so from the pass yeah and paved their
own way and I think the same is true for
do you think so back to Gears you think
they killed Marcus Venus - let me tell
you kill him - like why is he still here
like you listen to separate and to go
forward this is y'all not Nintendo
Mario's not gonna live
I mean Mario's gonna live with Nintendo
for billions yeah you're gonna still be
getting Mario Galaxy and you gonna die
from you're gonna be alive till all the
Master Chief and that's not gonna do
that there were no playing times before
they did they won't I'm telling you
you're not gonna lose any steam because
you know what that's gonna open auto
chat do you guys think that Halo could
survive of a bad
without Master Chief keep in mind they
got destroyed because they didn't have
Master Chief being played enough in Halo
5 this dude wants them to kill him I
whoa I think that you get a different
reaction if people like Locke more if
Locke was more likeable
I honestly date you know why that with
how it went because they hemmed in a
hard they didn't take a solid step in
either direction they try to play it
down the middle they try to show you
okay
they didn't because they made it seem
like your decision was gonna be an
outcome right that you pick right it was
I think we got a couple of years in a
couple of maze and hey and I think
that's pretty much how the how the the
fan base is kind of divided I think like
honestly you kill chief you could bring
them back right they do that they do
that stuff all the time they'll bring
them back though you whatever a
precursor maybe and you gotta find you
you gotta you gotta resurrect them like
Osiris you gotta go throughout the
galaxy to bring them back now I think it
would be super it would be super ballsy
to do that right now considering that
people's primary beef with five was the
fact that you don't have enough chief um
so yeah I think it would be that would
be nuts to do it now I think the first
story coming out of whatever Infinite is
needs to be a chief story
no question whether he dies in that
story I listen man got a kid like a baby
being surprised man I don't really care
like I don't have that attachment to
characters like that I don't I just want
I want the franchise to progress and
halos lore and adding you know this man
the law around that universe is deep
there's a lot of stories they can tell
smaller stories and then again go got
the super-g you're talking about
reaching ODST I think those games sort
of deviated a lot from what was
considered like the as the halo formula
in a way that made it I thought I very
interesting I liked being able to to to
sort of not be chief and especially with
ODST being a position where you were not
nearly as powerful as chief and
been affected the way you played the
game they kill katana
she's been crazy yeah exactly like they
they kind of did kill her and she suck
and now she's awesome other stuff so I
man they can't be fearful of blowing up
these characters and starting fresh I
know don't even like hello hello hallo I
love halo but I want it can't be stat
you can't stagnate if it's stagnated
we're gonna be having the same
discussion years from now saying the
same thing like why kill master Chi
finishin fatality says Victor Alice no I
want to decisive movement and you know
Microsoft has shown you want to turn
everything in the destiny no I don't I
don't care for that I don't what is
gonna happen I'm telling you I've been
telling you that as as a company if I'm
looking at it for a boardroom from a
business standpoint and I'm gonna
generate wealth not bucks wealth it lies
in the streaming it lies in giving them
a world that is constantly evolving and
interacting and story can be thrown in
and you went to a planet and you found
some story law there that so you can
gotta come here and when you start to
get the engagement levels up alright you
start seeing test patterns of it like
and see it thieves and stuff like that
right and everybody was laughing at sea
of thieves ma'am but the engagement
levels was ridiculous
it's still like one of those top tier
Xbox games in game paths that the
engagement levels that's high so the
level of content that you'll get in a
larger world that can they can actually
all flow stuff to that X cloud and stuff
like that they're gonna make such a
robust game that you're gonna constantly
keep going back to it they can't do the
same oh and expect different results
that
and that's why I know that the chat
jumped on me a little bit when I said mm
oh right but I mean mm Oh certain
sensibility is not an MMO and in the way
it plays are you talking about yesterday
no because destiny is not a real MMO
it's not it's not you just said you
didn't want it to be a row MMO just no I
want no like real like I can RPG MMO
sensibility where you created a world
online right and you continue to expand
on the lore of that world by adding
adding new zones adding expansions
adding more character classes things
like that where you actually expand the
world of Halo that's what I want to see
you guys remember a game that never came
out that a lot of people were super
excited about when they first started
talking about the 360 you guys remember
Huxley that first person your MMO it was
supposed to be that it was supposed to
be a persistent world where they it had
its own board has its own story the
player characters had agency in that
world in addition to NPCs actually
having real stuff to do in the world the
world felt alive in a way that I don't
think destiny feels I don't think anthem
feels that way I don't think the vision
feels that way I think all of those
games because of the fact that they are
looter shooters I think they feel more
like it's owned off everything is owned
off and it doesn't that's why I think
I've called it like a diorama in the
past you don't think it doesn't feel
like it's real yeah I feel what you're
talking about like when I thought
destiny was gonna be a whole expensive
world like World of Warcraft right I
thought it'd be a planet you go into and
or you can reach throughout the galaxy
but it's it's not like that you know you
like the cutscenes you have to fly to
the planet and I Maki breakfast in no
man's sky because I want you to
understand where games should be going
games and the developers for no man's
sky he I know he was super ambitious and
I know he made a lot of promises but he
believed in his product and his product
product on premise is where we should be
going
this shouldn't be a limit like you
should be able to fly your ship from one
place to the next if you want to go
through the galaxy it shouldn't be a
cutscene to get you to Planet X you
should be able to fly to Planet X but
ask for no man's sky comparison right
you want it to be something just it's
seamless yes it is it's supposed to be a
living breathing world they showed you
animals right they showed you living
animals and I don't think that was a
false narrative I think they actually
wanted you to understand that these are
the worlds that you're gonna go to this
this story that you're gonna go to its
gonna be alive it's gonna be more robust
you saw when they say infinite they
don't want you to limit your scope when
it comes to said title they want you to
understand that it's infinite in the
possibilities that will be presented to
him so the word is a play on words is a
double entendre when it comes to it and
you're gonna see how it's gonna go I
know it's gonna be a hard pill to
swallow for a lot of people but once you
start to understand that this is
necessary you want that regular stop
borderlands 3 how many people complain
that they didn't see anything different
in borderlands 3 from water lands to and
was pissed off so if they give you
another halo the same way to give you
the last halo you're gonna be pissed off
people want different they're afraid of
change but when it's good and it's done
right they accept it yeah I'd be okay
with any sort of big chains honestly if
it's if it's done right and again I
think for me story like III want halo to
have that story I want people to
experience the rest of that Lord there
was so much cool stuff in those novels
around halo that that I wish were just
part of a game that you could you can go
to these locations in the game and see
these characters again it's it's a big
undertaking but I think if you really
want to bring halo back in a way that's
three for three zone and not sort of
piggybacking off the Bungie formula I
think that's what you have to do I
really do sovereign I mean actual
question when you just use those words
it's a big undertaking
they said five hundred million dollars
it may be so that's a that's a lot of
bread exactly how do you get to see this
is this what I'm talking about you know
some games when it's like 20 million
like oh my god right but when you in the
board room and you have to release these
funds you're trying to get these funds
you can't go in there with the same old
so you gotta already start be thinking
out the box or when it comes like this
so don't if if you're looking for that
same old I'm telling you you're gonna be
disappointed yeah I think so
I'd ever really do think so I don't
think they've gone to all this trouble
and not show the game early on and been
working so hard on this brand-new engine
for it just look prettier I don't think
that's it I really don't same with gears
I think gears is gonna show more I don't
know I don't think to the level of
deaths of level of Halo but I definitely
do think it's it seems to feel a little
bit different from what I've seen so far
and I'm hoping for more of a departure I
don't sleep in that title at all really
no you know why because I think it's
gonna be the same exactly the same thing
I did I really didn't pay attention to
the story I just got from point A to
point B get today and the I was gonna
write it was beautiful it was nice when
they had the Thunder and the lightning
and it was good it looked nice on my
television and I was showing the HD
other people um that's about it but I
don't I don't see them guests need
something and I don't know what it may
mean right but I know you can't apply
that formula that they want to put with
Halo Infinite to it I know you can't do
that to that game yeah but I don't know
what direction you take it to change it
to make it fresh I think the same goes
with gears though I think these guys
have taken a long time to create a world
around the gears franchise they can be
explored further I mean they've done it
somewhat with the with the arts yes
that's coming I'm sure they're gonna
explore story in a different way in the
RTS and I think the characters and just
everything that's going on in that world
warrants being able to create something
around it that's deeper than just
a dudebro shooter I think it's just a
matter of them being willing to do that
so I mean I hope so
addict this is your topic you want to
put a cherry on top of this what you've
been waiting to say miss oak why we're
just idiots because he doesn't want my
reality there was the reality of the
halo to be the truth I'm telling you it
was in a sellout first of all I told
everybody I'm not buying the game I
stuck to my word also said if somebody
wants me to play that game with him and
my best bro was playing the game I was
like so that's nice my best bro
community what do you even have halo
channel subscribed on YouTube do you
even follow that look because I'm
telling you right now if they go the
direction you're going and they kill
Master Chief that franchise will die you
think so
it's not and think so the whole
community is behind that we're gonna
hear you but I don't quite believe you
in that you you're not gonna play that
game regardless of what game it is wait
well no no no if they kill Master Chief
what's the point of playing Halo why are
they gonna give me some random person
his weight was like that's the reason
that they did you split off and they're
warning Duncan but majority of these
spin-offs everyone died for a reason and
it's always gonna go back to the Master
Chief attic what's the color of chief oh
my god we're gonna go there again no I
want you to know I'm talking about the
color of his his suit what's the color
of his suit his Green is green why is
ready red and blue so popular why is
that whole narrative the
came out was so popular isn't you you
are you're making an attachment to a
character I just don't agree it doesn't
matter though if people thought of him
the way they would they wouldn't have
got the backlash for not using him in a
local multiplayer is what push halo once
you finish that that multiplayer is what
Hatter's like wouldn't know but your
point is look I think people attach
themselves to hey it's a Master Chief
more than you guys think they literally
got destroyed and reviews because you
only played as Master Chief like 30
percent of the story they got demolished
for it got destroyed what was the
reaction to what was the reaction to and
remind me because I'm not real arbiters
same thing okay it was a dab that it
wasn't like that because that's because
our burger was an actual functioning
member and they brought him from the
first one so people could you know they
can understand that and plus I thought
let's not act like Arbor wasn't at a
decent storyline talking from the
company's perspective of the war that's
the reason some people like that gunnery
you breathe some random-ass Spartan from
from galaxy six it's not going to do the
same thing on a random Spartan from
galaxy six but when you start to
understand that you have to become chief
you got to stop looking you can't become
chief your Spartan will be the new smart
you gotta make and forge your own role
what I agree with an addict in that
regard is that they've already given
chief a voice if you tell me they'd
never given chief of voice and you were
just
he was just an avatar and you have to
you imagining yourself in his suit
that's fine but they gave chief of voice
already so that's it's hard my voice to
give them a personality they've done all
of that like if this is before my friend
would agree but this isn't before halo 4
this isn't before they put an emotional
attachment to court on this isn't before
they've had intimate moments to make
Master Chief more of a humanized
character this is after all of that so
you mean to tell me they're gonna go
through all this trouble and then
they're gonna kill it
it makes no no his brains out for
Cortana
you you are see that that would make
more sense yeah you know that would be a
little bit right now you are 3/4 the
head cut off chief
how do I kill them off oh so epic it's
gonna be so epic is nobody can find the
second B so B no it has to be in
self-sacrifice and it has to be like I
said love for a katana I don't think
anything else works you has to be the
hugest sacrifice possible he can make
just the only way they were one of
there's a couple ways that they would
kill chief if they did tell me how would
you do it
I would kill for there's only okay what
comes two characters there's only one
other character in the whole franchise
that that would have that enough clout
he even killed cheese smash a tree oh no
not a truck that's arbiter arbors the
only person they would ever like you
alright so good let me ask you a
question how would you kill chief I
would kill that's that's a hard thing
like look you could go the direction to
where you know first off they've already
they've already went around where chief
was going to be you know that billing
from Halo 5 that they completely false
advertised the only way that you could
do it is some kind of scenario happened
to where the only way that they could
stop Cortana was cheap doing something
that put him that took out him and
courts on it but I don't see do I don't
think put her back inside his head and
then she takes over chief and they have
to kill chief they were never going to
do and you're never gonna hit so someone
has to kill chief who kills chief well
you know what's funny attic this is is
it gonna be like no listening has to be
a self-sacrifice that's the only way
from listen accurate we got to stop this
part alright because you're trying to
have a direct correlation from the last
Halo to this next one they're not going
to have any direct correlation from that
last Halo to this one you think they
said it's a secret
mr. I keep on Halo diagnosis people oh
listen I don't think to to have it move
in the manner that is supposed to move
in that man gonna die he fittin to go
you're gonna see a funeral you want to
you want to wanted to bend the knee on
this yeah I can give you a free I've
been the knee right now halo halo
infinite he doesn't die he dies I'm
gonna say right now he doesn't die by
the end of hail infinite halo 6 he will
not be dead that's your standpoint he
will be dead that's your standpoint and
by the end of my he will be dead that's
my state I mean he won't be dead that's
my standpoint what are the wages here
what are the wages means this means
right are we going beyond that it seems
very very that's your business or you're
always I just want your knees I will bet
you again take a game throat and bushes
I'm betting you your knees okay you are
actually you bet me again so you're so
confident you won't bet up again you
know what's funny I'm not one of those
egotistical do that you think you can
play that with don't worry he came at me
hard correctly no no no let me talk
sovereign someone that comes out there
you know what's gonna happen you don't
accept it but won't put up a game is
someone that is frauding like crazy
that's why I need a great fraud alert
you know how when you won't do stuff you
know how he feels about that he's not
giving you a free game that's the happen
he knows perfect I'm about to win I
would put a percentage on him dying in
this game it would be like 5% good and I
say a hundred percent and I want your
knees I'm not doing unless you put up a
game cuz I'll get something out listen
check it out check it out this was gonna
happen right you're not getting a bit
hidden obviously guess you ain't sure in
the bed here fraud like listen when he
dies I'm just a virtual means polls so
it's explained yourself you don't really
believe what you're saying
and you don't have to explain yourself
no one's asked to know to explain you
saying you're not sure about it yourself
bang bang that awful sound I mean you
could keep repeating that lame-ass slide
it's not gonna change the matter that
you're not sure what you're saying the
gauntlet has been thrown we'll see
because obviously they aren't different
they're on opposite ends of the spectrum
here on what they believe nobody's King
when he was comput know what he was
talking about the spider my hearing care
he said let's do it cuz he was confident
he knew he was gonna win that well when
I'm confident cuz he's not confident
he's about 50/50 right now he just won't
come out and say yes if he was a hundred
percent confident he just did that
knowing it no question setting let me
ask you a question right did I bet you a
game on spider-man yeah what I do what
game I got no you bet my knees that I
bet again okay that's all what last time
you won't do that so what's the
difference what because you are less
everybody's everybody's torn on this is
no says I think they could kill him but
not a hundred percent what does that
mean she's know is gonna be somewhere
somebody gonna implant his brain some
grain some places you got to go through
the galaxy to get his nose don't want to
let it go I I feel that though I feel
the fact that people don't want to let
him go it's gonna hurt even more when
he's dead I mean he's so dead you don't
have confidence in that wrap this one up
move on we have two more little topics
quick takes on stuff that uh that either
the Lord's weren't around to sort of
address when we were at PAX East or
stuff that just happened in the past
couple of days so so real quick I want
to talk about this rumor that Red Dead
Redemption two could possibly be
announced for PC in the coming weeks and
that it could possibly be announced as a
epic store exclusive I know attic has a
lot to say about this bird so I do let's
go I don't really want the world burn
I just want Twitter to burn yeah that's
true I like people melting down that
best is fun right well I see the reason
I want this to be true with this this
epic and red dead that's what we're
talking about right right I want this to
be true because I want I want to see
these people that have been hide that's
cuz like it's like I've always said it's
easy to boycott something you don't care
about you don't care about Metro it's
easy to say your ankle bye Mitch you
don't care about borderlines easy say
you're not gonna buy Borderlands but
it's harder to boycott something you
want to play so when they drop that Red
Dead on the epic store then PC people go
you know that you know that that Pikachu
mean that that's exactly what all of
them gonna look like cuz they gonna be
like well that they're gonna be asking
for features on epic like hide that you
are like cuz they wanna know what scene
they playing Red Dead it's gonna be
interesting dude I know I say
interesting a lot but wow I just want to
see more
I don't care where it's going I'm gonna
get it wherever
because I just want to see I just want
to blow out my PC and see what see what
it looks like but dude if this is the
case and you got to remember Borderlands
has already been confirmed by 200 verily
address something yeah please do
I don't understand where these PC people
are coming whoa you know would just
pirate it so you know because you can't
get something because you refuse to buy
it at a store that's good that's
available to you that's free to you
you're gonna steal it I have never made
sense to me and then people wonder why
these PC ports get poorly optimized
games because a mindset and the thought
process is buying these people like if
you don't want to play it stand by your
stand by your ground don't play why
don't give them money but that pirate
because you don't want to pay for this
is that on to the chat like they are you
know VAT he said pcs having a console
wars in there are no cog mentioned this
a couple of weeks back and if they're
getting a taste of that medicine that
we've been you know we listen for years
who cares about read boring - how did
this turn on me in a matter of not even
a second not even a second I mean I'm
just saying like he really cares about
read boring - like who really cares
about getting it is called riding your
horse or like you're not of a hat turn
my bad for trying to play it like a game
you guys have the attention span of a
flea that's right that's right
why can't the later part feces of horses
does not have to be pressed to 100 all
the time why can't you just chill enjoy
the surround
is a nice product why did they sleep
live five hundred some-odd people to
make that game so you can see the tree
so you can see no horse testicles they
want the wind is blowing the whole sorry
but I look you think that you're
drinking that red day cool a man you've
always been drinking too and I'm glad
they broke they date they don't they
don't milk it they thought this gonna do
the their own the Grand Theft Auto they
do this go do the online but about three
or four weeks after the online MS they
wasn't that bored me okay what can we do
on GTA that's right horse crap in the
Gulf alright so that your feelings on
the actual game notwithstanding King how
do you feel alright let me comment then
I say what he says I want to see the
world burn and that for whatever reason
people are not feeling that epic game so
I'm not even gonna I'm a fraud it myself
too cuz I couple weeks back I said they
had like they had what's my clothes I
watch dogs too for like seven bucks so I
got it on there right and then I check
to see if it the game comes up in my you
play store so as soon as I bought it
yeah the game composer my you play store
I said epic in the bushes I closed that
town and I downloaded the game through
you play which ii not much of it's not
steam level but it's been around longer
it's a little more fleshed out than the
epic game store so i fraud it and i just
i got it through do you play
so i whatever i don't really care about
if this is the only place this game is
going to be did you buying this crap
twice of course come on you couldn't put
a gun to my head makes me go back if I
can stop like that yeah so far into the
bushes
horse what what do you guys feel about
the fact that these guys are willing to
drop the entire bag to get these
exclusives right because we already know
Borderlands 3 is it's a six month
exclusive and takes otay to who is
willing to do that with a border last
game that has Borderlands is the people
been waiting for this game forever
um and they're willing to do that
obviously because epic just open up the
checkbook so do you think do you think
epic open opens up the checkbook like
for permanent exclusivity would with a
game like red that you can't why not
it's just it doesn't make a viable sense
I mean I won't give you it for six
months you can give me the bag and it's
gonna go over there and make some money
over there but as from a business
standpoint it doesn't make any sense
financially whoever's in the boardroom
that makes the decision to hell you did
you get he needs to be fired ASAP for a
game I tell you if a game like Red Dead
but again your opinions notwithstanding
I know plenty of people friend not pick
it up on consoles because they're
waiting for hopeful hopefully a PC
version cuz they never got a PC version
of the original one so I know a lot of
people were just waiting for a PC
version to bid now I hope it never comes
up I hope it never comes out and they
wait for the first one I hope they
released the first one on PC and
laughing I wanted to come out and only
be a quick story that's the only
scenario you know but I really do like
you know what to be honest what you're
solving I wish that scenario would be
true and they would release that game
only in epics tour I wanted I want
everything to be released in an epic
store I want steam to burn
I wanted to burn and go under they need
the BT that's what he wants he secretly
wants that so that Phil comes in with
the arm that's right
hey that's Phil that's Phil hold on hey
I heard you got problems shiny new car
paint come on I gotta get in this game
pass okay so that's not take on that so
the last thing I wanted to talk about is
something that they I think we were PAX
East when it really hit sort of a fever
pitch um everybody was sort of knee-deep
in Sakura and there was a not I'm not
King but
suckee Oh but articles started coming
out and these these happen around Souls
game all the time but I think for sucky
ro because of the fact that people
thought started noticing that this game
was harder in a lot of ways in a regular
Souls game or even blood-borne that you
know article started coming out up about
man this game needs an easy mode like
they they're not respecting their base
by not including the option to give you
an easy mode right and you know shout
out to smooth move and for everything
he's been doing trying to win that
thousand dollar challenge I know it has
not been easy so start out to him and
and you know playing a game that he's
not used to sort of playing that's not
really his lane and getting down and
grinding so I feel a certain way about
this i'ma let attic go attic first cuz
I'm an addict addict is a difficult game
conquer so I want to know what you feel
about this these games need some sort of
easy mode or you just gotta get good at
the end of the day like as long as it
was made like the raids and destiny were
you know it was made for the hard mode
and then they just put something in
there for people who are dumb and can't
comprehend simple movements you know
then cool I don't care like I really
don't like it they wanted to put an easy
mode in the game as long as it messed
with the core experience of the actual
original mode that was designed I don't
care like if they built shekar's die
twice and then they're like okay let's
what we'll do is we'll go ahead and you
know put in a couple more gameplay
mechanics and make an easy mode for as
long as it was designed after the core
game was originally designed and there
was no exceptions and it had to do that
I would be okay with that but that's the
only way I'm ok with it as long the
formica gameplay mechanics are not
messed up shout out to the PC do ya PC
modern have made like a a sort of you
could speed yourself over you can slow
down the enemy so that you can and
that's that's the easy move me to
release
inside the console additional body but I
will play it why because I'm not the
difficult game Conqueror and I don't
care to be I'm not playing carpet until
I get an easy move I'm done
see I feel what addict is saying about
the fact that after the fact right you
can you can add something to it to make
it more accessible to more people the
thing about it is and I think this is
just from from from software's
perspective at any point in time that
you give your players that option it
compromises the experience that they
were trying to make and that's that's
the point of those games right
especially when you talk about like say
all the games have something to do with
like like the world decaying and you
know everything around you is falling
apart and for whatever reason especially
in sucky role that the idea of death and
coming back and the consequences of you
coming back and how that affects the
world is integral so in a way it almost
has to be harder than the other games
because death is the point and death and
not dying is the point right so my only
beef with it and it's something that I
saw in an article that I actually didn't
even think about on my own and once I
read I said you know what it's right and
again some people might be for me over
this but when you were in a point in
gaming we're trying to be as inclusive
as possible there are people that
physically cannot play these games
because of certain impairments right
even with something like the you know
the Xbox are what Yuma call it that's
why I forgot the name of it now I like
that controller right so that to me is a
problem because again if we're trying to
be inclusive to everybody and especially
if somebody who wants to play that game
like if you're a person who doesn't want
to play that game don't play it fine I
want to play it but we know what I don't
like the level of frustration and my
control is a valuable so I don't need to
be busting up my controllers so it's not
you know our IP this moves elite
controller yeah put an easy mode in if
you want me to buy your games put an
easy mode in it stop ain't got time to
be submitting 40 hours on a boss ain't
got time for that
now I I don't I don't see any issue as
long as it doesn't
affect the core gameplay mechanic like
the core games no I do I do I want easy
you could play how you won't play but no
no I'm saying that as long as it doesn't
affect my hard mode oh I don't care what
the easy mode if it's there or not but I
do care if they build an easy mode first
and they just made that harder like I
want the core game to be built around
want the difficulty from software's
famous for making what then one day and
then they make another mode scaling it
back for easy mode that's the only way
this works for me I don't want it any
other way because I don't want my games
being you know a lot easier core wise
because they built the easy mode first
yeah I think we're secure though is a
little bit of a catch-22 because I think
just because of the aesthetics the
setting of the game the ninja stuff back
you know bacon and ninjas like I think
you they had more people interested in
this game then you would some you know
people who just are our souls fans right
or blood-borne fans I think that setting
just drew people's eye like me like I
again I enjoy those games but I'm not
you know head-over-heels crazy for them
when I saw this aesthetic it was a day
won by so I think just smashing keyboard
every night after PAX after we did the
uh the podcast or whatever right back to
Sakura so for me it's just the they sort
of did the maybe you do the aesthetic a
little bit of a disservice because to me
in a lot of ways it is one of the top
ninja games ever made like really it
really is but you really have to dig
deep you have to get good at that combat
to really see that flow to really see
that Channel five if you don't it's
gonna be a frustrating affair like
what's the problem I love these games I
do I really do I love these games I play
them you can ask everyone on this panel
I literally play almost every
fromsoftware game ever made I've beaten
them all I don't see how you can say
that it
easy motors is something that it
shouldn't be there look if it doesn't
affect the actual game why does it
matter well I think that's the argument
that if you ask from software they say
it affects how we feel the game should
be anyway I'm not saying I'm not talking
about a dev standpoint I'm talking about
a person playing these games if the
devil doesn't want to put it in it I've
always been a hundred percent on giving
the dev complete creative control over
all their games right but it let's say
that they did come around bloke and
let's put one in there you guys act like
most are boycotting this [ __ ] you know
we all know you ain't you still don't
think it up I think that it's okay to
put one in it as long as it doesn't
affect the core game before they put
easy-mode in it I don't see how that's
an issue I don't I don't I don't care
for blind man beat dark souls I don't
care how an issue is what a blind oh I
see someone beat dark souls is the
guitar so you know would I these are
very Ciroc band guitar something like
that we're talking about like two people
I had thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of million subs at the end of
the day if if they implied an easy mode
correctly that wasn't interfering with
the actual game why does it matter that
someone could go down and not up yeah I
think I think the argument holds true
more so for second role so like I said
that death mechanic but the fact that
the story is kind of linear in a way
that other Souls games aren't a
blood-borne isn't like part of you like
there's a lot of environmental
storytelling in these games particularly
blood-borne and particularly like the
souls games and you don't necessarily
get to see all of that stuff if you run
through it in one shot and you don't die
like a lot of that stuff is it comes
from you use constantly playing the same
areas over and over again where you see
little details or whatever that inform
this bigger story beast that you start
seeing as the game progresses whereas
second row it has some of that but the
game is a lot more littler stories a lot
more linear like its outright telling
you stuff and to be fair also what's
sucky row like they they've they made a
lot of like quality of life improvements
to that game that the past games didn't
have like you can pause the game right
my god like these people are crazy like
why can't there just be hard games there
is a heart giggling i'ma buy write and
play that hard game but if you a scrub
and you ain't good at games you can play
the easy mo to yo you there is room for
both
i'ma buy gusto Tsushima is it I'm gonna
get my new ninja I'm gonna buy it was
somebody rumored that was cancelled I'm
gonna I'm gonna buy Borderlands III on
the epic store and I'm not even playing
it on PC I got to support the matter I
support that crazy
kognito said he's gonna do it too so
there's two cells that we probably never
touching that ya never seen a game ever
ever ever alright guys so that's all we
got for this week thank you to everybody
in the chat who was kind you know this
is difficult as all hell all props go to
Cognito for doing this on a weekly basis
this is not fun
I'm sweating bullets over here yeah you
know the best part about it cuz you
started off with trepidation like you
deal with your first interviews better
as it went along thank you thank you
much and much appreciated I appreciate
well I will take card back of course
please my god listen man come come back
in you know strike down the uprising
it's fine by me as long as you let me
keep my head I'm good I'll be back I'll
be back next week once again like I said
there's no poll this week I'll leave
that to COG and we'll take care of that
next Oh as a poll going up the poll this
week is gonna be it should we kill
cheese or not now when an impromptu poem
yeah okay so first first line is gonna
be killed cheap second line of it'll be
kids again it is kill cheap
don't be mechanic mad and kill chief
and they'll send addict the first cut of
killing chief and the funny thing is is
that's how you roll make it unfair it's
unwinnable gotcha
let's control exactly that's how you do
you have to me King gets you into a
corner man and he's not you gotta read
that fine print you don't you've done
toast toast out rose man like addict
what's going on man tell people where
they could find you what's going on this
week will you be beating sucky road this
week yeah I'm probably be streaming
Sacro tomorrow I do want to thank kids
move for getting off the stream because
uh he was hurting us man we had like 20
viewers the moment he left we jumped up
like 90 was the moment he story about
those tech difficulties I sent them link
like three different ways that it did it
works I think it was on isn't like cuz I
joined the same link I sent him and he
probably did he probably threw something
at it like you probably messed up
something I definitely appreciated kids
always been a real supporter of the iron
Lords podcast he's gonna literally
stream this whole podcast to destroy our
viewership and it would but I appreciate
him getting off well all right you know
I could stream all day long but I'm
gonna end it right now
cool cool no doubt like Lord King would
have coming up I know we got boxing and
EXO is that fight talk combat talk worth
you've got collision karissa going up
against a female thunder I'm gonna break
that down I think it's about time that I
start acknowledging her accomplishments
um because we had a Christina Martin and
we had Laila Ali as the premiere female
boxers and what what Clarissa is doing
is a little bit more unprecedented for a
female fighter what I need her to have
is she's needs that nemesis she needs
that that I would hope this fight would
be that and I will break that down and I
would tell you what is gonna be how it's
gonna be but we have like combat talk
with the Kings know we have a Kos uh as
you can see
I start putting boxes down there at the
bottom so maybe if you zoom in you might
know what I'm gonna show this week only
there's a bunch of IOT Cheryl you know
we can lie to you
or maybe you won't know what's in there
because I have something else it's over
here
something else is over there and I got
like 13 or 14 waters over there in
another six or seven is over here and I
got more on the way so um what I want
y'all to do is stop stop looking at it
on Twitter because kognito is sick and
tired of me giving you all of that extra
all that production value so what I'm
gonna start doing is sending you a
picture and sending you a link and you
want to see it you won't have this you
won't have to go to youtube channel
you're gonna have to go to our Lords of
gaming dinette you're gonna have to
figure it out because no more am I gonna
put four or five hours into a Twitter
promo and you guys not following the
link so this debt is done so now you
want to see it go to the YouTube channel
and go check it out and shout out to all
those people that has been going to the
YouTube channel
um faithfully and and seeing the full
video because just shortchanging
yourself if you really want to see the
statues you want to know everything
about statues or why I have it in my
collection then you'll figure it out
when you get there but it's done they're
done now
kognito has pulled the cape of Superman
and told me stop giving you all that
extra no doubt man yeah yeah go ahead I
do have one little announcement you know
if anyone over there from Epic Games
ever stumbles upon this video put read
dead 2 on epics store however ever you
imagine if that wasn't a timed exclusive
it would be words anyway like we bought
it all right of course I'm Lord
sovereign the offline profile Illuminati
and love the single-player self is
experienced that's what I'm about trying
to hold it down this week for Lord
Cognito guys once again big shout out to
everybody from PAX East the entire team
out there King Kai snogged o MJ the Boss
Hogg honestly we went out there we went
hard man we went hard we tried to get
you guys as much coverage as possible
the Lord feeder for real for real so uh
yeah just look out for more that content
it's gonna be trickling out slowly but
surely what else shot out to the stream
team against Naldo MJ the boss boogie
potentially perfect dalabo
a dino if I'm missing anybody I'm sorry
and of course shout out to everybody at
Lords of gaming dotnet the only place to
go for your news articles opinion pieces
Lords of gaming dotnet shout out to
dizzy everyone over there who held it
down while we were gone who guys kept
writing articles guys who wrote articles
based on the videos that we posted I
know it wasn't easy but thank you so
much for all the work you guys do and of
course thank you to guys in the chat you
guys are always so loved I appreciate it
man I really appreciate it so that's all
we got man see you guys next week enjoy
the rest of your Sunday and we're out